die stunde der wahrheit
tv show kommt mit wwm wer weiß mehr
bikes und meine heutigen kandidaten sind
wir haben aber geübt wieso heißt
eigentlich lautet weil wir hat man kann
alles rein und wir fanden es sehr lustig
dass im hintergrund borno läuft und wir
also die beiden haben da geredet vor der
kamera und ich saß hinten und dann kann
man so gedacht hier ja was kann ich denn
machen ha so lustig machen auf voller
lautstärke vollbild und dann war der
kanal weg wir mussten halt damals gar
nichts und dann beim videodreh keine
pornos mehr
leider nicht leisten werden jetzt machen
für dieses quiz ist lautet das heißt
fragen über euch selbst beantworten ist
das so eine us millionär abklatsch hier
ich sage das ist eine eine optimierung
von parrot region alles klar
eine million es gibt nur fragen wir euch
also ganz leicht eigentlich alles okay
welches eure videos hat laut witz
dort kommt im durchschnitt die beste
bewertung
langeweile in real life zeitreisen liga
boss bud mercer setup calle de kannst du
überleben interaktives im video scheiße
welches davon hat die beste bewertung
die beste am meisten daumen nach oben
oder das ist gibt es platz gibt zeiten
durchschnittswert ja kinder die meisten
prozentual die meisten downloads
das ja kann also das letzte video von
kannst du überleben
hier lockt die redewendung in real life
geile idee übrigens geschenk ist über
wie viele kekse drei anspruch jemanden
keks gehen 23 b 334 oder ja immer ich
habe drei oder die leute sagen das ist
zu schwer das vielleicht wir versuchen
immer wir variieren endlich sinn
aber ich hätte es nicht gewusst also ich
hätte nicht gedacht dass du bist hat
schon mal wer alles richtig ja in eurer
parodie auf hdmi hängen im klassenzimmer
plakate aus dem geschichtsunterricht
wer fürs thema haben diese behandelt
kalter krieg gegen napoleon sonnenkönig
ludwig der vierzehnte oder de karl der
große
ich glaube meine frage
allah kalter krieg b napoleon c
sonnenkönig ludwig der vierzehnte oder
de carl der große polio ok dann lasst
uns doch das war ein zeichen von gott
wir nehmen napoleon fresse wir nehmen
das was wir neben der polio
würdet ihr wirklich bena bowle und einen
loben wollen ja das war ein zeichen auch
wenn's was man ist auf den plakaten zu
sehen von buchstaben in napoleon jetzt
sie wollten es so leider nicht was wäre
nach sehen sind wir rausgeflogen jetzt
aus diesem motto ding
darf ich euch das feierlich überreichen
er ist eine plastik ist nämlich nicht es
geht um die geste das erste mal dass ich
einen preis gewonnen
hallo unserem freund da hinten auch ein
stern gehe ich habe selbst leider kann
dabei jeder hat aber der hat ja jede
frage die ihm gestellten falsch
beantwortet es war zwar nur eine aber
gut da könnt ihr noch die flasche gleich
viertes mitglied ist